all right before star trek into darkness
comes out I'll be honest with you I
don't have time to review every Star
Trek movie that's existed it might be
fun I just won't have time do you want a
general summary here you go even number
Star Trek movies are good odd number
Star Trek movies are not so good it's
generally speaking that's ballparking it
we're still the worst is Star Trek 5
that one is well it's just almost
unwatchable it's it's pretty terrible
now we got to review the Abrams Star
Trek because that it has to happen
before Star Trek into darkness so let's
do that
Star Trek so Star Trek came out in 2009
it came out like two months before I
started doing videos I just missed it
and this is textbook case reboot that I
actually love if I think reboot that
really worked it's Batman Begins and
Star Trek I grew up a big Star Trek fan
so I was looking forward to start trying
for those of you out there who are like
I thought you said you love Star Wars
did we live in a world you can have both
you can be a Star Trek person and a Star
Wars person get used to it Abrams is
directing both now spoiler alert though
I'm going to talk about the spoilers in
this Star Trek movie no talking in code
here I'm just be warned
so Star Trek tell us the story of how
james t kirk became the captain of the
enterprise
it starts out awesome - it's this ship
it's not the enterprise's the USS Kelvin
Kirk's not even born yet this big-ass
ship comes out of nowhere and starts
kicking the out of the Kelvin I
mean immediately it's exciting in this
whole gets blown in the side of the ship
and this chick gets sucked out into
space and all the noise just cuts off
and you see her body just going doesn't
make sound though it's just I love it
when it shows that space has no sound
long story short everything turns to
the captain gets killed so George
Kirk takes over command of the USS
Kelvin and Chris Hemsworth plays Kirk's
father in this movie that's right before
Chris Hemsworth was Thor anybody he was
George Kirk Jim Kirk's dad gotta start
somewhere not a bad place to start
he's like everyone get to the shuttles
evacuate the ship get my pregnant wife
was going into labor right now to the
medical Shuttle get her out of here and
you're like okay George Kirk's gonna
fight him off and then everyone's
evacuating and she's like where are you
and he's like look I got to stay behind
and fight them off the shuttles will
never make it if I don't fight them off
and this is heartbreaking right
here I don't even care what anyone says
this scene hits me that's right you have
shirtless Ryan Gosling in your notebook
nothing don't give a have George
Kirk talking to his wife about their son
who's about two seconds all vol he's
doing a kamikaze into Nero ship and he's
dying man tears dude every time doesn't
matter what time of day doesn't matter
how many times I see it it just I choked
up you're like all right Kirk can be
that great this movie made Kirk cool
again the only reference that people
have nowadays the like the priceline.com
guy was Kirk and apparently he was cool
at one point but he really was in the
old Star Trek days Jim Kirk was like the
James Bond of the skies or at least
outer space I guess I wouldn't be the
sky would just be space oh we see Kirk
and he's kind of aimless he's not in
Starfleet don't get to that in a second
everything's kind of changed at this
point he's not
starfleet he's just like I already just
hit up the bars and hit on chicks and
Captain Pike who Star Trek fans remember
he was the original captain of the
enterprise he was like Jim Starfleet can
use you you can be like maverick from
Top Gun so we can have this underdog
who's kind of badass and people can
relate to you to root for in this movie
enlist in Starfleet please and so he
does but in that bar where we meet Kirk
that bar fight has one of the coolest
hits I've ever seen in the movie mr.
flying people are getting knocked around
Kirk grabs his bottle and smashes it up
against this guy's head the crack of it
just the impact of that bottle
shattering I'm like I really feel like
that bottle busted on that dudes face
love that hit man have the base jacked
up when you watch that scene I'm just
saying after that Kirk joined Starfleet
and now we have our adventure I saw a
quote from JJ Abrams before this movie
came out and he was like we're making
the Star Trek movie not for Star Trek
fans but for fans who love movies right
there I was like that's interesting to
say and people might not like it if
there's a Star Trek fan but I loved it
because he's like I'm making a
well-constructed movie not just some big
fan service movie the fan service will
be in the movie but I'm making the movie
primarily for people who love movies
let's face it that's people like us man
and I loved it and this movie does have
fan service has the Kobayashi Maru test
the Kobayashi Maru test we've heard
about in Wrath of Khan it was this test
it's a simulation for cadets in
Starfleet
it's unwinnable Kirk cheats and he wins
because that's who Kirk is because he's
awesome Kobayashi Maru was a word that I
used growing up to describe a no-win
situation because I was just raised as a
Star Trek fan so I just thought that
that's what that term was I thought if
you looked up Kobayashi Maru in the
dictionary if you like no-win situation
I didn't know it was made for Star Trek
he's just kind of stuck with me after I
learned that it originated in Star Trek
last week but I loved that they showed
it in this movie and it shows one of the
strengths in this movie it's the
strength arguably no not arguably it's
the strength it's the contrast and
relationship between Kirk and Spock that
drives this movie Spock was always an
iconic character in Star Trek lore but I
was always like a Spiker you're kind of
boring he's a Vulcan he's kind of
emotional aspetta
Spock is half-vulcan half-human this
Star Trek movie really illustrates that
Spock is conflicted inside his emotional
human side is logical Vulcan side
they're at war nothing to me really
Illustrated the internal conflict of
that until this movie this movie turned
Spock into a really complex character
and the polar opposite occur Kirk
assists know-it-all hothead Spock is a
know-it-all hothead one leaps before he
looks and
one really looks before he leaves those
have strong opinions differing opinions
yeah they're not gonna like each other
those strong personalities in that
bridge well like just one scene where
Kirk and Spock just get in each other's
faces in heat Kirk business buck-offs
box snaps he starts kicking the out
of him you're like oh yeah I know Vulcan
neck ribs here I'm gonna do pawn Farr or
anything just every move Kirk's trying
to block and note me decks um smacks him
in the throat chokes them out you're
like es Fox pissed
sorry Kirk Spock is just a better
fighter than you I guess and it's cool
to know that Kirk and Spock are gonna be
so close when they're older remember
when Spock was dying in Wrath of Khan
and he was all like half been and
always shall be your friend and to see
him hate Kirk it gives that friendship
and relationship layers I love it I love
the camera working this movie too
usually I'm not a big like rune the
camerawork was fantastic kind of person
but in Star Trek I loved it there are a
lot of panning shots there not a lot of
still shots in this movie that may
irritate some people but it just makes
the movie feel alive to me when a
filmmaker does that it can otherwise it
can also look really overused and
exhausting but in Star Trek it totally
worked this is one scene is one shot
Spock gets in the elevator pushes the
button stands there waits a few seconds
the door opens he gets out of the
elevator now he's in a different room
he's in the bridge now right there I was
like this movie just made me feel like
I'm actually on the enterprise the lens
flares are the big thing where people
are like I don't like them or I do like
them me I like stylistic stuff JJ Abrams
loves his lens flares
I actually don't hate him I think they
give a cool flavor to this movie if you
hate him I get it I mean if you're
easily distracted by that kind of
it would get to you I imagine it's not
going away anytime soon I'd like to see
if he holds back on the lens flares for
star trek into darkness or if they're on
full force in that movie this entire
movie is a new timeline so everything
that happened in the old Star Trek
movies did happen and then after all
that years later Nero and Spock
come back from before the Star Trek
movies happened and now time has changed
it makes it relevant people are like oh
they rebooted my franchise and I hate
that well this one is saying all
the other Star Trek movies they did
happen but doing that allows for some
time changes they're like oh well kings
in trouble I'm like all right let's go
save Spock's parents and save Vulcan
because they're not gonna wipe out
Vulcan no they wipe out Vulcan Vulcan
gets destroyed when that happened in
this movie I was like they're gonna fix
that though right they're gonna because
Vulcan can't just be gone no they don't
vault
is just gone now there is no coming back
from that Vulcan is destroyed and
Spock's mom is dead because it was
Winona Ryder I have some gripes in this
movie it's ultimately that some of the
casting for the extra characters I was
like are you just casting your friends
but not a writer as Spock's mom doesn't
detract from the movie at all but it
makes you go why her Tyler Perry is the
head of the Federation again you're like
doesn't detract he didn't play a larger
role I would start to get suspicious if
he was a larger role in the movie but he
wasn't but you got to think why Tyler
Perry and Nero was a weak character in
this movie was a weak villain he existed
to get this little ball rolling but
ultimately I'm like he could have been
anybody it could have been like this
pissed-off teenager named Timmy wouldn't
have changed the movie at all it's just
Nero's pissed and he's drilling holes in
planets and putting black holes in them
and killing them as a character you're
like II D weak link right there which is
why I think it's star trek into darkness
they were like fine you want a cool
villain Cumberbatch gonna wreak some
for the most part everyone did a
really good job
Zachary Quinto kills a despot Chris Pine
kills it as Kirk they're all really good
in this movie some of the physics I
question you meet old Spock in this
movie Leonard Nimoy's in this movie
again giving validity to the entire
process of this reboot but he mind-melds
with Kirk and he shows him that in the
future this supernova was gonna wipe out
the galaxy duh galaxy a supernova can
wipe out the gal I'd never heard the
possibility of a supernova wiping out a
galaxy and galaxies billions of stars
and planets and I I just I think they
might have made a mistake
I don't know I don't have a 28-year
degree in astronomy or astrology or any
of that just saying I've never
heard of that being possible you know
and they're skydiving from outer space
to Vulcan and they penetrate the
atmosphere then they just do their job
first of all I didn't think you could
skydive from outer space so think you
just flow unless you're tired about
wolfie gravitational poles suck them in
again I'm not a scientist or anything
but my understanding is when something
tries to penetrate the atmosphere of a
planet they burn up and when you're a
human being you die just going down like
this is like entering the atmosphere in
3 2 1
whoa I've heard volcán has a thinner
atmosphere but I still don't buy it i
buy it like i buy the fact that a
supernova can wipe out a galaxy I just I
don't but I roll with it because it's
sci-fi I don't think you can transport
people either so hey when you go into
warp drive people would splat to the
back of the ship and they die there too
speaking of warp drive the warp drive is
awesome in this movie on the other Star
Trek movies is all you're like ah off to
your adventure this one is just booming
they just they're gone and you're like
you really went from zero to holy
the other side of the galaxy like that
alright a couple minutes but still fast
I'm concerned with star trek into
darkness and the fact that I don't think
it can be better than this Star Trek it
might I mean to have Cumberbatch
and they still have Chris Pine and
Zachary Quinto and the entire cast has
come back I'm just saying the
relationship between Kirk and Spock in
this movie was so good I don't know how
something in the next movie can be
better than that by the end of Star Trek
Kirk and Spock reached an understanding
worse like I get you if they go back to
bickering too much I'm gonna be like I
thought we were over this I thought we
grew as characters in the first movie
but so we'll see how it goes but in the
end as a Star Trek fan and a movie fan
Star Trek was fantastic I can watch this
movie all day every day it's fun as a
casual watch as fun as an investment
it's totally nailed the characters Kirk
was a badass Spock was a badass Star
Trek I believe was my favorite movie of
2009 and it is awesome tacular
to be honest with you I have a
memory but I do believe it was my
favorite of 2009 have you seen it if you
haven't that would be surprising and I
think you should and what did you think
of it I'm really curious about that
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more